Jennifer Law Review that she hasn't
decided if she will talk to Ryan or not
but you know J law has been crazy busy
traveling all over the world promoting
red Sparrow which hit theaters today and
the party should continue this Sunday
because Jen's homegirl will be here too
how do you make the Oscars fun well I
hope Emma and I are gonna have a real
Saint shouldn't just cancel and leave me
I'm gonna have to face makeup so I sent
my hair makeup team home and now yeah we
remember that look from the Globes night
and now she's just as fearless from
Washington DC to London to New York I
don't know and who doesn't love her
latest clap back when j-law wore this
plunging Versace gown in freezing London
she got some hate with Jennifer hit back
quote get a grip people I would have
stood in the snow for that dress because
I love fashion and that was my choice if
you ever want a photograph of yourself
to be disseminated me last night I was
just like I was kind of like depressed
of it I was just like I'm just gonna be
annoyed and she was like she was like I
hear you but I have to say like people
see that dress a lot more because of the
controversy you knows like that's true
but is this a little TMI with Howard
Stern maybe not I'm like drunk or you
know if there's karaoke bros midnight
train to Georgia I will take my top off
under any circumstances and how about
this confession to Andy Cohen about
getting tipsy during red sparrows New
York premiere I look like I have had
electroshock therapy in my head I was
like I'm a goth dream and then I look at
the photos and I'm like I'm a goth dream
on crack drunk last night I'll watch
what happens live and he surprised the
obsessed Real Housewives fan with cast
members LuAnn and Bethenny
and watch what happens if she handles a
callers wild romance question are the
rumors true that you and Brad Pitt were
secretly dating no but I've never like
I've met him once in like 2013 so it was
very random but I also wasn't like in a
huge hurry to lik debunk it
[Music]